how do we play defense against this like
say the millionaires or whoever but okay
so nuclear war happens
i mean these shelters are not going to
fit 330 million people so it's not like
there are these shelters
how are you going to manage shelters if
something were to happen and even an
individual family okay with food
shortages
or any of that stuff you know you got
people that own a lot of weapons
themselves a lot of you know ammo a lot
of guns just in case something were to
happen
how does the average family as well as
the us government
proactively played defense in case
something were to happen
okay
ah
let me uh
one of the things we should have done uh
was listen to ronald reagan and
and deployed the strategic defense
initiative
uh which was uh you know uh that and
that's one of the things we still could
do as a government
uh you know the strategic defense
initiative was designed to render
nuclear missiles obsolete by estab
deploying high-tech space-based defenses
that could shoot them down before they
could reach us
you know the best solution or the the
best defense against the nuclear war is
to not get hit in the first place by
shooting down the missiles before they
reach our territory
and uh that's what reagan had planned to
do
and you know history goes through
uh cycles where technology will
sometimes favor the defense and those
tend to be more stable safer times
because if you're the defender you have
to worry less about getting attacked
because the technology favors a
defensive posture okay other times in
military history uh uh the technology
favors the aggressor it offends favors
offensive operations that was like world
war ii
uh you know when uh the introduction of
tanks in combination with air power and
mobile infantry
gave
the advantage to aggressors and to
people who conducted offensive
operations and those are more dangerous
less stable times because he who strikes
first tends to win we are living in the
most dangerous and least stable times
because the invention of nuclear weapons
mated with missile technology enables
you to
destroy another country's
retaliatory capabilities
in 30 minutes or less
uh
and then and now and it's getting worse
and worse uh the technologies are
getting better at better uh at being
able to destroy retaliatory capabilities
with cyber attack with emp attack you
can do it at the speed of light
and so the truism that he who strikes
first wins is becoming more and more
true you know to the point that the
temptation to do nuclear pearl harbor on
us may become irresistible and we do not
do nuclear pearl harbors our our nuclear
strategy is not based on striking first
it's based on striking second and
deterrence and being and that and that
puts us in an increasingly vulnerable
and dangerous position but we could
reverse this potentially and this was
the vision that reagan had wasn't just
his idea there was a brilliant scientist
robert jostrow who wrote a book called
how to make nuclear weapons obsolete and
it was the inspiration for this to
deploy space-based missile shield you
know that would be able to intercept
these missiles edward teller the great
the guy who invented the hydrogen bomb
was all for this he was working on uh
there were a number of of technologies
that were very promising that sdi had
and we should bring back the strategic
defense initiative one of these
technologies was called brilliant
pebbles
and it was ready to be deployed by under
the clinton administration but the
clinton administration for ideological
reasons
uh you know believed in mutual assured
destruction uh you know thought the abm
treaty was the cornerstone of strategic
stability and the left has always hated
ballistic missile defense it's funny uh
you know they they hate nuclear weapons
but they hate ballistic missile defense
too and so they're against both us
having nuclear weapons or us having
ballistics do they publicly hate it but
privately love it or is it just they
hate it period they hate it period okay
for ideological reasons
especially if it's in the possession of
the united states they hate it they
don't seem to have be that much bothered
by russian or chinese nuclear weapons or
their defenses they don't complain about
that but whenever we try to improve our
nuclear
weapons or improve our defenses the left
screams bloody murder over it uh and and
it's happening in the biden
administration now i mean i just
explained how some of our most important
nuclear systems have been cancelled by
president biden you know that we really
need even though we're under this great
threat from russia what a time to be
canceling our nuclear strength um uh but
uh
we could deploy brilliant pebbles
probably in five years for 20 billion
and it would completely change it has
the potential of completely reversing
this situation so that we would then
have the advantage as the defender and
uh and
the the best scenario would be to start
a defensive strategic arms race with our
adversaries because i wouldn't care if
if they were deploying brilliant pebbles
and strategic defense initiatives of
their own because if you're in a
defensive arms race that makes the
situation more and more stable and both
all sides start to feel more and more
secure because they're better and better
defended against a against the first
strike so there is a technological way
out and that's one way out but
if i could speak to a larger issue
you know because i uh you know
i don't want to come across here as if
technology is is the only card we have
to play we have a bigger uh
potentially a more important card to
play uh you know and the way we should
be thinking about
waging the new cold war
is the way we won the old cold war
we have uh
for all their military power and nuclear
power and specialized weapons like emp
and all the rest
uh we have an enormous advantage
i hope we can hold on to it in the free
world and that is
you know i i believe our systems uh
believe in
have a truer understanding of human
nature and of how to organize the good
society our belief and freedom okay is
one of is a
is is a great advantage that we have
over them
our systems are
uh
uh
the vision and unfortunately we're
moving away from that so
maintaining
free elections in this country discourse
rationalism being the way we were for
example under the reagan administration
all right uh you know when you could
have conversations and and and
rationally solve problems we need to get
back to being that way the further away
we move toward authoritarians type we
become as vulnerable as they are to this
and this gives us staying power the fact
that our understanding that our society
is truer to human nature is gives us
greater staying power so our objective
should be
to you know to split this
the russian chinese alliance in the new
cold war to try to contain china
uh to avoid getting in a nuclear any
kind of a war to get it and avoid any
kind of a major war with with these
powers as long as we can to avoid that
because that's a game that they are more
likely to win than we are you know uh
they're better prepared for it they
they're that's what their whole
societies are geared toward they they
exist for warfare okay
uh
and uh the soviet union
you know was the most formidable
military tyranny that ever existed in
history okay but it was based on lies
and these other systems are based on
lies they're based on a fundamental
misunderstanding of human nature of what
makes the good society and these
internal contradictions if you can
avoid fighting them long enough they
will they will destroy themselves and
self-destruct if you can just
avoid getting in a conflict with them
long enough and contain them for long
enough that was the strategy that worked
in the cold war it was based on an
article called the x article that was
written anonymously by a guy who later
was discovered to be george kennan a
state department brilliant man who said
this is how we need to deal with the
soviet union in the long run you know
they will fall of their own internal
contradictions
they are so paranoid they're going to
spend themselves to death
with their defense budgets so just try
to keep the peace and and and and
contain these guys long enough and
they'll just self-destruct and will win
and that's how we won the cold war and
without it becoming a world war which is
a miracle in history because normally
when you have superpowers confronting
each other you know whether it's uh the
persian empire and alexander's macedonia
or the carthaginians and the romans uh
you know uh these things usually end
badly they usually end with a huge uh a
world war in effect to resolve the uh
the dispute so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]
you